wir schauen jetzt nach afghanistan dort
herrscht krieg die extremistischen
taliban die sind weiter auf dem
vormarsch und die menschen sie fliegen
und hierzulande wird darüber diskutiert
wie viele menschen kommen werden und wie
viele abgeschoben werden soll
deutschland auch gefährder weiterhin
nach afghanistan abschieben auch wenn
die taliban jetzt so sehr auf dem
vormarsch sind wir haben bei der politik
nachgefragt
dort wo krieg herrscht dort wo die
taliban immer weiter vorrücken
doch hier im studio wollen wir diese
frage diskutieren wie geht die situation
weiter was bedeutet das für deutschland
klaus stroms wird uns im studio
was wir sehen diese bilder gesehen wie
die taliban die terroristen weiter fort
rücken und wir sehen dass immer mehr
menschen zuflucht suchen werden auch in
deutschland und man steht vor der großen
frage
und auch da sind sich die parteien nicht
einig dass ein abschiebestopp geben oder
nicht wie gegen den in dieser
schwierigen situation ist irgendwie muss
die politik regeln
also ich glaube das entscheidende ist
dass wir uns jetzt nicht drücken
oder um es härter zu formulieren erneut
drücken um eine klare positionierung und
deshalb glaube ich dass die frage
abschiebungen als großes ganzes
verbunden mit asyl thematiken aber jetzt
ganz aktuell auch abschiebungen nach
afghanistan zu dem wichtigen
wahlkampfthema werden können
für mich zum beispiel als bürger ist es
ein eine der drei vier koordinaten an
denen ich meine wahlentscheidung
festmachen werde von wem der kandidaten
von welchem kandidaten kriege ich welche
abschiebepolitik und das glaube ich
müssen wir einmal durchchecken für alle
bürger denn da wird auch schon wieder
nicht offen geredet und das werden wir
uns genau anschauen müssen
letzteres gilt dass genau das machen
einmal auf die antworten der drei
kanzlerkandidaten schauen und wir fangen
einmal mit den grünen an also
abschiebungen nach afghanistan weiterhin
ja oder nein
die grüne kanzlerkandidatin annalena
baerbock hat da erstmal keine klare
antwort gefunden die hat auf das
parteiprogramm der grünen einfach
verwiesen interessant aber dass ihr co
chef kohler co parteivorsitzende robert
habeck sich geäußert hatte in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
er sagt jetzt sei der zeitpunkt gekommen
die abschiebepraxis zu revidieren also
das heißt indirekt was klaus das heißt
abschiebestopp nach afghanistan
nachdenken ja deutschland schiebt
derzeit ja ab wenige menschen fast
ausschließlich straftäter und das will
robert habe offensichtlich stoppen sein
gedanke ist man kann menschen nicht in
eine kriegsregion
abschieben den gedanken muss man schon
mit wegen bei der eigenen entscheidung
was er offen lässt ist ob sein sein
seine einlassung sicher auch auf
straftäter beziehungen an der stelle
verläuft für mich die klares das klare
bemessungskriterien wer auch nur ein
wenig offen lässt dass straftäter
menschen die in deutschland straftaten
schwere straftaten begangen haben
womöglich im land bleiben dürfen
der wird meine stimme nicht kriegen und
deshalb sollen die politiker aus meiner
sicht an der stelle auch klar sprechen
ich finde auch legitim zu sagen wir sind
ein humanistisches land wenn man eine
humanistische tradition wir sind ein
reiches land
wir können auch noch mehr menschen bei
uns beherbergen finde ich vollkommen
legitim ist nicht meine meinung aber man
darf das sagen und man darf sich dafür
auch wählen lassen
man muss dann allerdings auch damit
rechnen dass man deswegen nicht gewählt
wird und deshalb muss an der stelle
glaube ich das ganz einfach dürfen
straftäter die nicht deutsche
staatsbürger sind in deutschland bleiben
oder nicht ja oder nein und das ist kurz
führen oder nicht groß sind da ganz
anders an dazu sagt kreuzen oder nicht
kreuzchen
wie soll man mit dem thema umgehen das
sagt armin laschet kanzlerkandidat der
cdu er sagt die lage in afghanistan
erfordere eine laufende bewertung und
sorgsames vorgehen bei rückführungen
wenn deutschland straffällig wird hat
seinen gast recht verwirkt der grundsatz
null toleranz gegenüber kriminellen
erlaubt keine ausnahmen
also da klarer haken dran es wird nach
armin laschet aussage weiterhin
abgeschoben und nach afghanistan
straftäter müssen weiter konsequent
abgeschoben werden auch nach afghanistan
sagt armin laschet stand jetzt also sagt
ja auch sorgsam immer wieder überprüfen
sondern er ist sozusagen der der erbe um
nicht zu sagen thronfolger weil es
eigentlich falsch also nachfolger
mutmaßliche nachfolger von angela merkel
im kanzleramt die eine andere politik
migrationspolitik mit anderen
begründungen seit sechs jahren sozusagen
verfolgt jetzt aber vor einigen tagen
eine historische wende jedenfalls auf
der tonspur eine historische wende
vorgenommen hat und vielleicht ist das
die ausgestaltung dieser wende die die
kanzlerin vom gegeben hat dann
glaube ich ist ein haken dran allerdings
armin laschet wird vielleicht mit den
grünen koalieren und steht denn dann
noch zu dem wort sagt er macht er es zur
koalitionsfrage sagte er wir können nur
koalieren liebe grünen wenn wir uns
darüber einig sind und können die grünen
ihrer wählerschaft gegenüber das dann
mit gehen also da bleiben bei mir
zweifel ob das dann nicht wie wir
älteren wissen ja schon was dann
passiert das wird in den
koalitionsverhandlungen zur abgerufen
abgerufen
es bleibt irgendwie bestehen aber doch
nicht ganz und die wirklichkeit zeigt
dann dass armin laschet davon abgerückt
ist also laschet muss als nächstes
hinterlegen dass das für ihn ein
kronjuwel von koalitionsgesprächen ist
und damit scheiden ehrlich gesagt die
grünen als koalitionspartner aus deshalb
ist es verlangt eine wichtige frage
der hat sich immerhin festgelegt du hast
ja klarheit eingefordert die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten hat das bisher so halb
gemacht einer hat es nicht gemacht der
spd-kanzlerkandidat der vizekanzler
olaf scholz beziehungsweise seine spd
die hat darauf keine klare antwort im
moment abschiebung nach afghanistan ja
oder nein
wo also soll man da sagen olaf scholz
ist da offensichtlich in einer art
zwangsjacke seiner zwei seltsamen
parteichefs denn olaf scholz selbst so
wie ich ihn über viele jahre auch als
bürgermeister in hamburg wahrgenommen
habe als amtsträger verschiedene ämter
in der bundesregierung in verschiedenen
bundesregierungen glaube ich ist näher
bei lassen
alles andere würde mich sehr wundern
wenn olaf scholz jetzt erklärt
also man kann hier leute abmurksen aber
kann dann auch hier bleiben das würde
mich sehr wundern aber er kann es
offensichtlich habe mir angefragt also
und so wie es unsere art ist nicht
einfach da zweimal sondern also intensiv
und das heißt nicht erkennt unsere frage
nicht er will nur nicht antworten und
das bedeutet da ist irgendwas in der spd
zwischen einer klaren positionierung in
der frage und wir wissen nicht genau und
unsere eigene linke und sind wir als
sozialdemokraten nicht den schwächsten
am meisten köpfen können wir können ja
mal erzählen wie lange wie viel tage das
dauert bis olaf scholz sicher festliche
und bis die grünen sich ebenfalls ganz
klar fester festlegen abschiebungen nach
afghanistan auch für straffällig
gewordene hier in deutschland ja oder
nein
das heißt jetzt sind glaube ich zwei
tage verstrichen mittlerweile seit der
anfrage an olaf scholz für zählen weiter
und was machen um vielleicht die
motivation bei denen die sich nicht
festlegen wollen sich so durch rubbeln
wollen bis zur wahl ein bisschen
anzuheizen und erhöhen und sie zu
motivieren wir motivieren ja so ungern
in deutschland motivieren weil die
kandidaten nochmals jeder der sich dazu
nicht äußern schreibt der afg
massenweise wähler zu wer das also
verweigert diese aussage macht sich
schuldig an einem erstarken der ränder
und das will ja wahrscheinlich weder die
grüne kandidatin noch der
sozialdemokratische kandidat also sollen
sie sich äußern und zwar so klar dass es
jeder verstehen kann nicht irgendwie im
gesetz so und so und internationale
vereinbar diese frage geht nur ja oder
nein
und das wollen wir wissen und das waren
wir herausfinden und das werden sie auch
beantworten müssen gegen den fahrschein
abschiebe stadt ist auf jeden fall die
fdp da schauen wir mal kurz was fdp chef
christian lindner dazu sagt gefährder
und straftäter dürfen sich bei uns nicht
sicher fühlen sie müssen aus deutschland
und in ihr heimatland abgeschoben werden
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren